I've been quiet about this but I'm
probably not it's probably not good that
I've been quiet about this is a segment
of the show I like to call I told you so
[Music]
so you guys remember when the stock
market dove down and I told you that it
would come back and it was dropping
dropping dropping dropping dropping and
everybody's don't cash out your 401k you
remember me being on the air some of
you've been listening for years and the
markets dropping it's dropping from
14,000 it goes all the way down to 6,400
or whatever went down - in March of that
year at the bottom the world's coming to
an end and I keep telling you you
remember use me using the line you don't
get on hurt on a rollercoaster if you
don't jump off that you know when you're
investing in your 401k you don't cash
out your 401k don't cash out your 401k
don't catch that your 401k don't cash
out your 401k and then the market came
from 6,000 now it's at 18,000 and so the
money that you would have cashed out at
the bottom is an hour worth three times
as much if you had a hundred thousand at
the bottom you've got three hundred
thousand and that's if you put nothing
more in it
now that's an i-told-you-so but there's
a better one there's a better one during
that same period of time people are
screaming at me I'm getting entire blogs
and YouTube goobers and all these people
posting Dave Ramsey's an idiot do not
lose the day rims he knows nothing about
what he's talking about because he's
telling you to not invest in gold I've
you've heard me say on this show over
and over and over don't put money and go
Gold sucks as an investment it's a
horrible rate of return over its
historical track record and as soon as
the economy begins to heal just a little
bit gold prices will dive I've said it
over and over and over and over on the
show and you conspiracy theory people
with water bottles and generators in
your basement and all that crap or
screaming at me because I don't know
what I'm doing and I don't know anything
about the world is actually coming to an
inn and you don't know anything by the
way gold is down 40% since August
2011 it Peaks out right up around $2,000
an ounce you know what it's selling for
today just over $1000 cents so you go
bugs you put a hundred thousand bucks in
that you know what it's worth 50 this is
a second of the show I like to call I
told you so
I told you I told you I told you I told
you not to put money and go but Davey I
understand Gold's and it's his hedge
against inflation where's your hedge is
that how you hedge against inflation
lose half your freaking money you're a
genius
so I got to get this out of my system
every so often because I get so you
would we can bail my hate mail here and
half of it is from freaks that are
buying gold that are going crazy on date
you know and you know they were you know
flying saucers brought them here you and
believe the crap that comes in the mail
Zulu the god of whatever told them to
buy it I mean it's just like the Mayans
the craziest of the crazy is out there
and man it's it's bizarre so and there
are some people that were fairly
semi-intelligent that think that the
world's coming to an end and they've
just figured it all out which makes that
means they're intelligent but they're
not wise and so they went in bought gold
because you know Dave when doing in
comes what we're gonna do when the
economy crisis you know that a gold gold
standard or off the gold standard our on
that fiat money don't buy gold don't buy
gold don't buy silver don't buy let
don't buy precious metals no buy
diamonds as an investment
don't buy precious metals commodities as
an investment period gyms don't do it
now if you're a diamond broker you can
make money doing diamonds okay I get
that but you playing around with
commodities and thinking you're going to
call yourself an investor because you
read some stupid butt book buy some
sideways character who's predicting the
end of the world you're going to lose
your tail in and now you have
and let me he'll tell you the difference
in this and the stock market went down
date but it came back oh I can't go
comeback it's not going to come back
it was artificially high and it was
based on one thing fear and when invent
the only way your rate of return on an
investment comes is based on emotion
then it's never going to be a stable
investment when you invest in mutual
funds it's not based on emotion it's
based on the rate of return the actual
dollars created by the companies that
the stocks are owned by the mutual fund
company it's like when you're buying a
piece of real estate you can investment
you can look at the piece of real estate
and it creates a rent roll the rent roll
creates an Noi a net operating income on
that piece of real estate and you can
capitalize that Noi and give the piece
of real estate of value based on the
income and is generating gold does not
generate an income
the only reason gold goes up is when
people are afraid and goals goes down
when they're not as afraid guess what
they're not as afraid right now it
dropped in half basically so I've been
telling you over and over and over and
over and over and over and over for what
Blake my god Blake sitting in there
today because James child's out on
vacation it's been a decade we've been
doing this that we've been I've been
doing the show 25 years but for a decade
we've been hearing from these gold bugs
and putting up with their crap and their
hate mail and their Twitter nonsense
blocked blocked blocked blocked blocked
you know and had to block them off a
Facebook because I get on there screwing
up our Facebook page where we're trying
to help people because they're freaking
nuts and now it's in half so here's the
this is a segment of the show I like to
call I told you so
shut up there you go all right I had to
get that on my system I just looked up
saw an article come across as I was on
the break and it got me started because
I hadn't seen I noticed that gold had
tanked as far as I had predicted it
would tank I didn't know when it was
going to tank I just know the basic
philosophies of investing and what
creates investment rates of return and
gold doesn't fit that model it's the
same reason you don't buy an Apple watch
okay it's going to be worthless in a few
years can you would you buy a $10,000
Apple watch and what do you do when they
come out with the new one I know
they're not but they have the gold
version or whatever this 10,000 bucks
art the other day somebody's shown me at
the website if I had $10,000 piece of
technology that bling technology you
might as well just throw the stinking
thing out the one because it you know
they're going to come out with version
whatever next week they do that all the
time so you're gonna buy the Apple watch
buy the cheap one because they're going
to come out with version whatever the
apparently the cheap ones pretty cool
though so but buy the cheap one because
it's a throwaway baby just like your
cell phone is so think think think think
think people think and if you think
it'll lead you to where you have money
it's just the strangest thing because
very few people do it this thing called
thinking
[Music]